today all three of you will get your own
country i've always wanted to rule
people here's how it works chris do you
want this plot of land sure i'll take it
carl do you see the people in this cube
yes they are the civilians of your
country you are in charge of them you
are in charge of the blue country let's
go and chris these are your people hey
look at them they look great i'm gonna
give you guys 30 minutes to build an
epic country with your people can we do
that in that amount of time rome wasn't
built in a day it was built in 30
minutes and at the end of the 30 minutes
these walls will fall and you guys will
go to war there'll be diplomacy betrayal
consequences it will be insane
are you guys ready aye aye captain all
right your people are now falling into
the world go to your discord call with
your people and lead them let's go
everybody listen to me i'm your leader
we have to beat the other in 30 minutes
we have to do this all in 30 minutes
guys yeah i'm gonna start giving you
stuff wait but how did mr beast choose
we don't have time for that we have 30
minutes i am not gonna lose this all
right chris i am now in your chest so
what chris what's your strategy our
strategy is to get our defenses up and
get everybody in enchanted diamond armor
so you're gonna build a fort then you're
gonna gear up your people yes all right
hey chandler i am now and you're called
another right what's another one right
yeah all right all right all right all
right all right all right build an epic
fort do what chandler tells you good
luck comrades we gotta get an enchanting
table somebody find lava i'll just spawn
one chris is in creative mode and he can
give you guys whatever you need crazy oh
my god they're all asking now
i'm dropping 64's of obsidian i need you
guys to use this to start working on the
castle if you die in the game you die in
real life what up red team chris's team
is very organized chandler's team is in
complete and utter chaos i think this is
the best team i could have gotten jimmy
when i joined chandler's call they all
immediately screamed at the top of their
lungs
but you guys have been pretty civil in
25 minutes you will be going to war with
chris and chandler's army good luck oh
no no no no lava bucket ah sorry sorry
sorry sorry sorry sorry sorry sorry
sorry sorry i'm sorry it was an accident
i misclicked miss click chris i'm back
how's it going i accidentally just
poured lava on everybody lovely all
right be careful with the lava guys that
was my bad don't worry we'll get more
stuff you guys haven't even started
building your fort yet what is the
potion for giving you guys exp that i
can throw
one person one person one person of
experience everybody level up i'm gonna
give you guys a bunch of gear and armor
and whatnot i'm gonna start lighting all
the trees on fire to make room for you
guys why would you light our trees on
fire didn't you plant 20 million or
something everybody make sure you're
sharing it's us our team versus the
other two teams we've got to win if you
guys get the dub i'll give all of you a
hundred dollars itunes gift card let's
go let's go let's get that itunes gift
card
and get the dub if you have any
duplicates of anything throw them in the
chests okay you guys need to start
working together i'm back and i will say
you guys are by far the furthest of all
three teams yeah how would you say
things are going carl everybo everybody
is doing well i think we're getting
communication much better now if you
guys want to win you'll share uh we're
getting it slowly done all right guys we
need people to start building we've got
to have like an impenetrable base we
have to work together boys we can do it
we can win if we work together pog
moment pog moment hold on hold on i got
a pog moment okay
what are you dropping elite so they can
fly carl's last one person chandler's
lost one person and you guys have six
dead players i'm sorry it was an
accident i misclicked so chandler what
is your battle strategy we're gonna get
everyone geared up and then we're gonna
build a base and then we're gonna
destroy chris and carl who are you
attacking first chris or carl whoever
comes first meanwhile this is so
stressful everybody's asking me for
things i'm going as fast as i can boys
what else do you need stacks of
netherlands
oh yeah yeah attention 15
15 more minutes until the war begins
chris is there no order there's no order
but it's working everything i hear i'm
just throwing it to him carl is this a
base or yes yes it's a base what do you
think do you like it i mean
i'm just stressed i'm stressed guys five
minutes remains who does green team hate
you got four minutes until you go on
your rampage all i'm saying red team is
you got a target on your back watch out
okay oh i'm not even worried i'm really
not concerned we're gonna kill him
chandler what do you recommend your team
does uh i think we're going full attack
join the diplomacy discord call okay how
do you do sir he's doing good how are
you doing so stressed out 20 seconds and
you can't spawn anything else
three
two
one no more spawning gentlemen remember
you are fighting for your people now go
lead them to victory all right
the walls have not fallen this is
chris's face this is carl's base and
this is chandler's face the walls are
falling go go go all right everyone be
prepared use your end of pearls if you
have them let them take each other out
guys everybody listen everybody listen
they're able to attack us now here's
what we're gonna do we're gonna stay
hunkered down all right so green team
you built up in the sky are you gonna
drop lava on carl's base yes
oh oh they're you're dropping lava on
them hey they're shooting arrows at us
i'm gonna go check it on carl do they
even know what's happening guys guys
grab your obsidian make some ceilings
chris tell me this isn't the most epic
thing look lava's falling arrows are
being exchanged left and right it is a
war zone all right we're gonna drop lava
on them unexpected and then just start
bombing them with tnt oh oh oh oh right
there oh okay no no no no stay stay stay
hey stay stay stay yeah
oh i'm stuck chris chris you got people
on the border fighting hey there's
people on the border fighting guys
it's fine i'll stay in this room as long
as you guys don't intentionally try to
kill me again oh taylor there's red
people flanking you they're baiting
they're baiting don't do it i'm on the
front lines for my team i'm on the front
lines so what are you gonna do there's
like 20 green people above you how are
you going to attack them i dare them to
come down full damage is on okay sweet
now they can't just jump perfect chris
look how many people you have up here i
know you're just camping above them yeah
we're playing the long game bro we're
winning this is war red team i'm back
and i come bearing bad news what's the
bad news you guys currently have 28
players still alive chandler still has
33 and the team reigning down on you has
31. you guys are in last place with
players livestock i'm not even actually
concerned about that guys guys guys red
team and blue team are going to war
they're on each other's border don't
fight we stay in our base there is no
reason right now guys look they're
fighting down there they're all fighting
drop lava drop lava drop lava in that
area retreat retreat oh dude this guy's
almost dead are you guys gonna get him
retreat retreat retreat guys guys guys
be aware be aware of the border okay be
where the border is coming in i'm gonna
bring all the boys into my discord call
and have a quick diplomacy meeting uh
good luck gentlemen i love you may the
best man win blue team wins how'd you
guys like the lava getting poured on yet
so carl you guys are bunker down your
fort chris you guys are flying high and
chandler you guys are just squirming
around the middle of the map we are
controlling the center all right
diplomacy meeting over back to your
corners remember your army wins they all
get 100 itunes gift cards hey guys
borders moving be aware turn around the
border guys wait the zone's moving in
gentlemen i've called you here this is a
dangerous mission you guys can do this
go snipe red team good luck gentlemen
hey everyone everyone red's about to
attack look at them i feel it they're on
that wall right there okay on my mark
we're gonna jump down okay go go go on
my mark go jump to chandler attack
chandler's team right look at my
beautiful men go
fly my pretties everybody go right now
attack chandler's team go go go go guys
mayhem's breaking out down here there's
a war get chandler's team right now take
their land all right red team they're
flying down from above the zones close
enough this is where you dig deep you're
trapped in the corner but you can still
prevail guys stop hitting me you're my
teammate i'm literally about to die i'm
about to die if you guys keep carl died
carl died and they banned him yeah you
guys killed their leader now it's the
time to bum run all i bum rush them we
killed their leader they're confused
they're coming everyone prepare arrows
attack just you guys know red team is
currently in last place they've lost
many men they're being slaughtered down
there chandler's low everybody turn
around dude they're teaming me go go
breach breach they're coming they're
coming they're coming go go go go go
they're coming up they can't make it up
to the motherland we will protect it oh
green came down chandler's team only has
seven people remaining just bum brush
though oh chandler's about to die
what the heck yeah boys hey chris don't
you have a kid i do have a kid and don't
you want to raise that kid i do guys
aren't you sitting here you're not
raising your kids that's true guys let's
kill them all go go we're stacked we got
this go boys oh they're coming down
they're right there they're right there
get them chris is right there go now go
now you win this drop down and get them
oh they killed me yes all right the zone
just fell down again everybody be aware
of the lava be aware of the lava they
double to me but here's the thing i
found out where their base is it's on
top of literally underneath our like
where we spawn the zone dropped again
good luck it's a free-for-all i believe
in every single one of you you guys got
this he has 12 health 12 health nine
health blue's over green's over we got
this where all right where are you guys
hiding at underground yeah oh green
right there green right there cool kyle
on the surface cool kyle on the surface
10 health there he is the second we went
into hee haw oh no oh my god it's like a
blast
you're the last one alive holy cow dude
i can't do anything for you i wish i
could the swarmer you like ants oh my
gosh here it is five health five health
attack and he died we did it
congratulations red team i'm kicking
green and blue teams but thank you
everybody for watching hit that
subscribe button we'll see you in the
next video